alors j'ai un petit truc à vous faire
lire quand même tous les deux non pas du
tout maintenant on ouvre en même temps
au moment où tu dis cette lettre à l'ex
est en train de devenir la miel dans
laquelle jules demande en mariage
[Musique]
menés d'entrée a changé ma vie tu as
changé ma vie alors pour cet événement
j'aimerais que tu sois la marraine
plusieurs raisons d'abord ce sera le
premier mariage griffe démission
et puis il ya tous jeunes et moins
jeunes homos qui ne s'assume pas qu'ils
ont peur et qui grâce à nos mondière
phoques à tout ça
[Musique]
c'était un très très beau moment
vraiment dans l'amour est dans le pré on
à mathieu et alexandre avec nous merci
mathieu avec 112 est magnifique les deux
sens dans mes chéris on est tellement
heureux pour vous ça a été un coup de
foudre à l'est de la havane charmant
ouais vous êtes heureux là je vous
l'aurais on vous voit heureux sans
régler déjà l'image on vous heureux tous
les deux c'est vrai que c'est ce que est
ce que tu t'y attendais alex pas du tout
mais alors pas du tout il a bien joué
son jeu il a caché les lettres ouais il
a été bon
il a été mon club mais tu sais que si tu
sais que je n'avais rien dit à personne
ni à la production ni à karine rien mais
ma mère ni à ma soeur mais je vous dis
ça restera je vous dis un des plus beau
moment pour moi de l'amour est dans le
pré
un vrai bon et je vous suis vous allait
tellement bien ensemble c'est tellement
magnifique tous les os et quand le
mariage le 2 juin le 12 juin je peux
peut-être amené à orchestrer un traiteur
un jeune j'ai des traiteurs les mecs
sains tout ce que vous voulez cacher
halal tout je veux tenir bon je vois ce
que je peux faire est ce que vous avez
est ce que c'est important pour vous de
le faire à la télévision parce que j'ai
c'est que vous avez dit vous avez envie
d'ouvrir d'autres la voie à d'autres
couples et j'ai l'impression que c'était
vraiment important pour vous de le faire
dans l'émission et que ce soit vu par
des millions de personnes
ouais alors déjà moi j'ai pris ma
décision cet été quand alex a eu un
grave accident de cheval et que tu
arrivée à l'hôpital et là j'ai dit on va
perdre de temps parce que si tu veux moi
j'ai une grave maladie et on se dit
toujours que c'est moi qui vais mourir
en premier et là je me suis dit merde ça
saute c'est lui qui va jouer en premier
donc on va pas perdre de temps après
j'ai voulu vraiment pas scénarisée mais
je voulais lui faire un énorme cadeau je
pense que on a eu cette chance d'avoir
été regardée par des millions de
personnes et je pense qu'on avait un
message à faire passer parce qu'on est
deux personnes on n'est pas des
militants lgbt et on est des dégâts
normaux et le faire passer comme ça le
scénarisé comme ça c'était un beau
cadeau pour les militants lgbt qui sont
dégâts normaux aussi à tous voilà mais
c'est vrai que voilà vous êtes vous avez
vous vivez votre vie vous voilà vous
n'êtes pas dans la revendication et la
fois
et entre vous ça très vite marché déjà
lors de la lettre et du speed dating
on a senti le courant passait rue du
regard regarder les de regarder la
regarde et on va revoir l'extrait
c'était quand même mon coup de coeur
quand beaucoup coeur de la halle de la
lettre alors là franchement c'est du
lourd a physiquement alors on est sur du
monde vaste et p1 voilà temps je me
couchais là il ya un troll ah bon je
suis ému
je suis muet
un bon gars un peu plus chez un gros
gars hockey vote aussi
[Musique]
il y aurait tant de charme timide ouais
ouais on peut déstresser la non
anticipation qui transpire un peu
[Musique]
[Rires]
pour moi j'en écoutais way
[Musique]
vous êtes trop mignons tous les dossiers
et comment comment ont réagi vos proches
et les gens qui vous connaissent dans
quand il ya eu cette demande qu'est-ce
qui vous ont dix étaient tous très
heureux pour vous il était complètement
heureux ma maman a peut-être dit c'est
pas un peu précipité
mais je lui ai répondu mais tu sais
pourquoi aller doucement quand on
connaît notre rythme mais les mamans
elles disent toujours ça existe toujours
que c'est précipité mais après elles
sont contentes
ouais tu vas voir quelle va être
contente autour du mariage c'est
vraiment la première fois avoir à 45
valais c'est vraiment la première fois
que j'ai envie de passer le cap
mais très beau c'est la première fois
que tu as un coup de foudre comme ça
ouais où tu te dis voilà c'est cet
effort ou tu te dis c'est la personne
avec qui j'ai envie de finir ma vie quoi
j'ai envie de partager ma vie voilà mais
le dernier quoi c'est vraiment ça ça
transpire de la lettre o
alors il faut que tu saches ne bat ça
m'agace mais jamais mais pas d'émissions
choses réelles bah oui c'est ça mais bon
mathieu et alex moi je voudrais revenir
sur un sujet un petit peu un petit peu
plus grave qui nous a beaucoup touchés
et un truc plus grave qui s'est passé
vous avez donné une interview cette
semaine et vous avait révélé avoir reçu
des insultes et des menaces de mort ça
c'est un truc vraiment qu'on supporte
pas ici dans l'émission et franchement
ça nous a un peu touché c'est pour ça
qu'on voulait vous soyez à ce soir parce
que on veut pas que ça se reproduise
qu'est ce qui s'est passé en fait si tu
veux jusqu'à une certaine celle
l'épisode ya quinze jours ou trois
semaines on s'est vraiment embrasser si
tu veux éviter salue le courage de
montrer deux garçons sont passés avec la
loi est un gros bateau et 7 cette image
a dû fixer dans la tête des deux saisons
groupe apx tennis tu veux quelque chose
ils avaient en face d'eux si tu veux la
réalité et on a reçu des messages mais
on va vous venir en chantier on va venir
crucifier une semaine ça vous a tous ses
saints alex après honnêtement on s'y
attendait un peu quand même
on sait que le monde n'ait pas choisi
nour et qu'ils feraient des commentaires
de ce genre a donc commencé à tomber
l'eau c'était bien de sanaa quand même
c'était violent non c'était violent
c'était quoi le plus violent que vous
ayez reçu c'était ses oreilles à un
moment donné c'était cette femme qui a
dix ans que c'était une femme qui a dit
mais dieu est sur le chemin pour venir
crucifier
alors je lui réponds parce que je lui ai
répondu dis bien à dieu de faire
l'essence avant de venir
non mais non mais c'est vrai que ces
menaces à ce qu'elle vous ont fait
regretter un moment d'avoir participé à
l'émission pas du tout cas pas du tout
moi au contraire je mets au contraire et
j'ai dit ramic m6 se montre vraiment les
brezina la voix est si c'est vrai
jusqu'au fond du sujet donc jamais vous
n'avez regrettez vous êtes dit on a
peut-être ça peut-être mettre notre vie
en danger
est-ce que les gens vous reconnaissent
dans la rue bah ouais bon coup et quelle
est leur action ils sont ils sont cools
avec vous ils sont contents ils sont
heureux pour vous avant je t'écoute
super heureux on était à auchan cet
après-midi ils étaient au chômage après
midi au rayon fromage on a fait acte à
redon mois et coûte cyril c'était un
truc de fou et plein de gens qui sont
arrêtés vont baisser le pied et cetera
des jeunes filles qui l'ont dit bravo
les gars et donc a énormément
c'est si agréable parce qu'on a on a
passé alors on a fait passer un message
et les gens l'ont été parce que vous
avez reçu des menaces les choses
changent donc voilà vous avez reçu
également beaucoup beaucoup je suis sûr
de messages de bienveillance et de
messages disant bravo à vous et merci
parce que c'est vrai qu'ils et voilà
c'était c'était top et on le redit m 6
bravo m6 d'avoir montré ces séquences
telle qu'elle est et n'a pas voir couper
bravo 1 dans cette série je pense que le
succès de cette saison qui est encore
grand l'année dernière c'est avant tout
grâce à eux bien sûr je suis d'accord on
suit l'émission et qu'on a vu le premier
speed dating était mignon qui l'on
pouvait plus tous les deux à se bouffer
du regarde a aidé hier soir c'était ce
que je trouve ça chouette c'est qu'ils
disent
c'était pas prévu en fait que karine ne
soit pas au courant que la prod ne soit
pas au courant c'est à dire voilà ils
vivent leur histoire nous on est témoin
et bravo bravo les gars pour ce que vous
avez
alors bravo ce qui est beaucoup ressorti
de l'émission vous concernant c'est le
fait que vous êtes tout le temps en
train de rigoler ensemble vous avez fait
beaucoup beaucoup de fans dans le
programme regardé mon sens du terme
[Rires]
je te mets une grosse tartine ce que je
sais que tu aimes bien grosse partie
donc nous sommes fabricants de pipes un
bruit hier à oui alors je te tiens à te
dire ceci n'est pas un gode 10 des
couilles c'est l'os des chiens moyen des
fruits de mer profonde thème la mouille
toi n'a pas l'habitude des cats et les
gens n'ont pas autant mathieu alex
j'adore vraiment voilages un type mais
est ce que vous avez reçu des consignes
de la production vous disant foyal un
petit peu mollo sur les blagues de cul
cul ou pas du tout peut-on rire rien
j'ai au toit que pendant le tournage
vraiment nous a oubliés les caméras
discrètes lointaine c'est ça qui est
bien c'est qu'on s'est embrassé aussi
mais vraiment aucune consigne pas du
tout
eh bien les chéris je voulais vous
souhaitez énormément de bonheur vous
dire que vous êtes magnifique tous les
deux et on prendra de nouvelles et on
espère que le 12 juin ça va rester un
jour vraiment magnifique et on immuable
et j'enverrai un cadeau j'enverrai une
table de ping pong c'est pour moi c'est
cadeau ok c'est pour moi les gars je
vous fais des normes bisous et bravo
franchement j'ai craqué sur vous et je
suis pas le seul
vraiment vous êtes un exemple persique
merci le shérif et soyeux rouge